Speaker 1: All right.
Let's get into Friday feedback where we hear
from some of you, your messages across different
platforms.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com.
Feel free to leave a comment on YouTube.
It might be featured here or post something
to the subreddit.
Really, whatever you prefer.
First one is from Wolfie.
Wolfie says Mr. Pacman.
Hello.
I've been watching your content.
Nearly five years since Trump's bizarre presidency.
But I do have a bizarre.
Yeah, I do have a question to ask you.
I'm okay with your opinion and I'd rather
keep it between us.
Well, I don't do that.
It's all either on the air or not at all.
But we'll keep you anonymous.
What is your view on LGBTQ, same sex marriage
and the whole things relating to it?
I am a gay male, but I think as an outcast
it's totally getting kind of corporate.
Anyway, just wanted your opinion.
I mean, you can share it on YouTube, but I'd
rather remain anonymous.
Good.
We are keeping you anonymous.
Wolfie.
Could be anybody.
My views on LGBTQ, same sex marriage, and
all of it.
I have been a staunch and powerful ally for
the LGBT community for as long as I've been
doing this show.
I've been an advocate for gay marriage for
as long as I've been doing this show.
These these aren't even controversial or contentious
issues for me.
And we have been following the evolution of
the political and social narrative around
those issues for more than a decade and a
half on the show.
And so there are probably hundreds of videos
that I have done on the subject.
There are also, for newer viewers or listeners
of the show, at least a couple dozen interviews
that I've done over the years with overt,
rancid homophobes of different kinds and flavors
and sorts.
And more recently, as I'm sure people who
have been following the political discourse
are aware, in the United States, the homophobes
have shifted towards transphobia and focusing
on the trans community.
You know, there is a movement on the right
which loves to say there is no more hyper
represented group in the United States than
LGBT folks.
You've got a, you know, pride flag at the
United Nations.
There's pride parades, there's everything,
gay pride.
But this is a group that is so overrepresented
relative to their size in the population.
You know, the counterpoint I would make to
that is this is a group on whom there is so
much focus because for decades the right just
can't leave folks alone.
And has activated.
First it was we need to defend marriage.
I remember when that was the whole thing.
Then all of a sudden there's gay marriage.
We've had it for years.
Everything's fine.
Nothing bad has happened.
Now the focus is on trans people.
So to those who say it's an overrepresented
movement relative to its population.
The obsession seems to be coming from the
right and from those who want to take rights
away.
All right, Wolf.
So I hope that that's I hope it's clear and
I hope I'm kind of giving you a perspective
on my views.
Eleanor wrote in from California about MAGA
preppers.
This is interesting.
Eleanor says, Hey, David, I fell down a right
wing rabbit hole and noticed some alarming
things.
MAGA Twitter feeds are filled with ads for
survival gear for the end days after they
defeat the left in the Civil War.
Their advertising pamphlets on how to protect
yourself legally if you shoot someone, self-defense
laws, etc..
Fascinating and terrifying at the same time.
So this is this is an interesting thing.
Prepping.
Has a religious component for some.
Now, I want to be really clear.
Don't email me saying the preppers aren't
only religious right people.
I know that there is non-religious right wing
prepping and there is also left wing prepping.
I understand that I am a very casual prepper
myself.
Very casual.
I have like a can of tuna under the desk taped
in cases.
Having an emergency.
I can pull it out and just eat it.
I guess I need a can opener, but I'll deal
with that later.
But there has been a history of religiously
oriented prepping in the Mormon faith.
Prepping is a big thing, but also an evangelical
Christian circles.
There has been shows like The Jim Baker Show
and others.
Alex Jones products have had a prepping aspect
to it that is maybe a little less overtly
religiously based, but but it's still there.
So that's not surprised at all.
What they've done recently is they've just
shifted the reasoning.
Ten, 12 years ago, a lot of it was like the
rapture.
You've got to be prepared for the apocalypse.
And when all of that happens, you're going
to want to have this food storage.
Now, it has shifted a lot, too.
You know, there's this Marxist dystopia that
we're heading towards where there will be
no food availability, or if we have another
pandemic, the liberals will shut down the
food supply.
So you better have it.
So the language has changed around it, but
there is actually MAGA prepping is just the
latest sort of outcropping or protuberance
of what is a much larger right wing and often
religiously oriented prepping community.
And when they add in the gun elements to it,
it is it is certainly scary stuff.
Graham wrote in and says, Hey, David, welcome
back.
Hope you enjoyed a nice break.
Guess your your guest hosts did an excellent
job as always.
And Graham goes on to say, I'm sure it hasn't
escaped your attention, but I noticed the
following.
You're YouTube subscribers right before the
right wing hate mob.
1.66 million.
Your YouTube subscribers after the right wing
hate mob over 1.69 million.
Seems that went well for them.
Exactly.
As I said in the previous message, the whole
thing created noise and it probably made a
bunch of new people go and check out your
channel thinking to themselves.
Sky seems like a rare, sensible voice and
end up subscribing.
I know it's been painful from the standpoint
of advertisers, but I find it difficult not
to be amused by how poorly this worked out
for the mob.
Yeah.
Listen, I've said to people the entire tweet
scandal regarding my tweet about the Nashville
shooting and prayer and it getting all the
way to Donald Trump jr posting about me and
candace owens and others.
Speaker 6: David Pakman does not have a soul.
He doesn't have a soul, right?
Speaker 1: It would have been uniquely good
were it not for the fact that people started
harassing my dad and other people online.
Right.
And the death threats and all of it.
It would have been uniquely good.
Now that everybody's forgotten about it, a
lot of the good is left.
We've got like 40,000 new subscribers on YouTube
and we have like a thousand people signed
up for paid subscriptions on the website,
all of that.
But yeah, Graham is right, which is to some
degree this backfired on the right wing mob.
Let's look at our subreddit user redacted
posted.
I find it funny how failed former President
Trump is touting Florida as third worst in
the country for many things in his so-called
statement stating how Florida is third worst
in COVID cases.
Third worst in COVID deaths, third worst in
crimes.
Doesn't that strike anyone as No wonder, since
Florida is the third most populous state in
the nation and no relevance whatsoever.
That Ron DeSantis bonus was governor.
Does he really think his followers are that
dumb to take his claims without a grain of
salt?
Well, yeah.
His followers are accepting those claims without
questioning them.
The reality about Florida is a very mediocre
story.
Now, I know people will write to me, I'll
say.
But David, you go to Florida all the time
and you talk about how great it is.
I enjoy certain parts of Florida.
That is absolutely true.
I also am aware of the real COVID numbers
in Florida per capita.
When you look at COVID numbers per capita
in Florida, adjusted to the population in
Florida is very mediocre.
It's not nearly the worst death rate and it's
not nearly the lowest death rate.
It's not nearly the worst case rate or that
it's just a mediocre state overall in many
ways.
There are parts of Florida that are doing
well and parts of Florida that are doing less
well.
But economically, as far as education goes,
as far as all these things.
Florida's very mediocre.
And what's funny is Trump used to talk about
how great Florida was when he wanted to talk
about how the the approach to the pandemic
from right wing states was better.
Now he's saying Florida is terrible.
It's the same Florida.
It's just Trump's telling a different story
about it from the YouTube channel.
YouTube user Douglas Duke Vote Clown says
MAGA now stands for My Ass Got Arrested, which
is funny.
But then another user protest to a which I
can only imagine means Second Amendment has
a blistering conspiracy theory about the Trump
arrest.
This user says he was not arrested, didn't
ride in a cop car, didn't get handcuffed.
Dems just made the biggest mistake because
they got nothing on him.
It's already backfiring.
We'll see.
Well, yeah, we will see.
That is a wild conspiracy theory that there
really was no arrest.
Of course there was.
There are real, fair questions as to what
will happen in the polling thanks to the arrest,
it seems.
It's a little helpful for Trump in the Republican
primary, but probably damaging in the general
election if Trump makes it that far.
But we will see.
But Trump didn't really get arrested is really
something else.
One other note about the Trump arrest, and
this is a really good point.
Spicy dragon posted quote, I guess New York
City isn't so big and scary as to keep the
Republicans away.
True.
A bunch of these Republicans who always talk
about how dangerous New York City is swarmed
into the city for Trump's arrest.
Ask how many of them were terrified or attacked
while here.
Did any of them actually go and show crime?
I'm a lifelong New York City girl and have
never been attacked, mugged or murdered yet
as far as I know, lol.
Yeah, I mean, listen, my experience in New
York City is regularly one where I never even
see crime.
Obviously big cities have crime.
What is important, of course, is what are
the crime rates?
How do the crime rates separate from or contrast
with the narrative about democratically led
cities or the most dangerous?
We know that's not true.
We know about the red state murder problem.
We know about all of these things.
But it is interesting that there was not a
single story.
All of these Trump supporters who came into
New York City for the arrest.
Not a single story of even witnessing a crime.
Never, never mind even being the victim of
such a crime.
And remember, the crime rate, including property
crime and violent crime, is higher in Oklahoma
City than it is in New York City.
Those are the facts.
They're not very convenient for many on the
right.
All right.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Sign up.
Join pack, Mint.com.
When you do that, you really do get access
to the bonus show instantly.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: Very much so.
Use the coupon code.
24 starts now.
Will see you on the bonus show or otherwise.
I'll be back with you on Monday.